I've let you bozos handle this long  enough we are doing this my way  Jennifer Aniston's new Apple TV series  the morning show is receiving quite the  buzz yes  et caught up with Jen on Tuesday where  she dished on what it was like working  alongside her co-star Reese Witherspoon  it was a no brainer  we've just loved the idea of where a  working together the subject the show  itself the world behind the scenes it  was just sort of and the timing it was  ripe and it was ready and then as we as  you know you know me too happened and  then the whole world turned upside down  so we kind of had to you know  wonderfully and willingly incorporate  that issue into into the show another  thing Jen is incorporating into the  morning show is major star power so does  this mean we could be seeing at least  one of her former friends co-stars any  one of them would you have you put them  asking not yet  [Music]